[MUSIC PLAYING]
THUSHAN AMARASIRIWARDENA:
Good morning, everyone.
Thank you.
[CHEERING]
Thank you for coming so
bright and early on this 8:30.
And thank you for those
who are watching along.
We are so excited to have you
here because in the next 40
minutes, you will be
experts in making games
on the Google Assistant.
We're going to discuss why
we are serious about play
and why we think
you should be too,
and who is excited
to play these games.
And then, we're going
to get into tips
of how, with words,
pixels, sounds,
and the code to make it happen.
And then lastly,
what you can do to be
found on the Google Assistant.
Before I go any further,
let me introduce myself.
I am Thushan.
I am a product manager
for fun and delight
on the Google Assistant.
And I'm joined by Andy.
He's also fun.
He's our team's creative lead.
And Ralfi, who is our product
manager on Dialogflow.
And while he doesn't
have fun in his title,
I can guarantee you he's fun.
We are a really big team of
writers, engineers, designers,
sound gurus who drive the
personality and delight
of the Google Assistant.
This team crafts how we respond
to lots of queries like tell me
a joke, to how are you doing,
or a surprisingly popular ,
one which is hey,
Google, I love you.
People say that.
And the reason we do this is
when you think of the Google
Assistant, everyone thinks
it's about getting things done.
And that is absolutely true.
We're here to make
your life easier.
But we're also here to
make it a lot more fun too.
And that's our little
slogan for our team.
We build apps like a trivia game
called "Are you feeling lucky?"
And the reason we do
this is so that we
can learn how to
make these games
and make sure that
those APIs that you need
exist so that you
can go build them.
We also build templates.
And we worked with
BuzzFeed recently
to bring them on board
onto the Google Assistant.
And where you can find
out what dessert are you.
You know, all those fun quizzes
that they have on their site,
now you can play through
the Google Assistant.
And we also work with
awesome startups,
like Volley, who made a game
called "King for a Day."
That's one of the first that
runs on these smart displays
that you've probably
seen around.
And we're excited to
show you those apps.
For example, they run on the
smart display right here.
And they soon will be
running on phones and TVs.
And we try to make
it easy for you.
Rest assured all those awesome
Google actions that you've
already built can get upgraded
with ease, with technologies
you're very familiar with--
HTML5-- to make that happen.
So I'm sure many of you are like
us, where when you were a kid,
you wanted a talking robot.
I always wanted Optimus Prime.
And now, we have it.
It's called the
Google Assistant.
And that is quite an
opportunity for us.
This is one of my
favorite charts.
Each curve here is
the adoption curve
of new technologies over time.
And as you can see,
each one gets sharper
and has higher
adoption rates as we
get closer to where we are now.
And then, you look at us--
smart speakers.
Now while it's small
right now, that curve
is the sharpest of them all.
People are running
to these devices
and adding it to their
homes around the world.
Now, you probably think
of the Google Assistant
as primarily coming through
these-- the Google Homes
and tons made by third parties.
And that's definitely
the way to think of us.
But we want you to think
of it as more than just
those devices.
This Assistant is everywhere.
It's in your kitchen on
those smart displays.
It's in the living room on TVs.
And most importantly,
it's on the go.
It's in millions and
millions of people's pockets
on their phones.
And we think that's
an opportunity
to reach users in a variety of
modes, in a variety of places.
And we believe it's
a new type of play.
We call it conversational play.
And while we feel like we're
in the black and white film era
of this-- like we're still
learning how to go build these
games--
we do know a couple things.
When we look at
who our users are,
we're seeing a couple of
patterns of who they are.
They're millennials, they're
families, and they're kids--
perfect game players.
We also want to highlight this.
This is "Angry
Birds'" rise to fame.
And what's important to
note is it took a while
before "Angry Birds" became
one of the seminal games
on touchscreens.
Smartphones were released.
And it took about two
years before "Angry Birds"
even came out and rise.
And this is where
we are right now.
Smart speakers have
been out for a while,
but there's an
inflection point that we
believe is going to happen,
particularly around play.
And we're down there.
And we believe that one
of you, many of you,
hopefully all of you will
be on that curve coming up.
So I'm going to hand this
off to Andy, who will talk
about building blocks of play.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDY PRATT: All right.
Thank you, Thushan.
So I'm Andy.
And I am also officially fun.
And what I would like
to do is talk to you
about the building blocks of
great conversational gameplay.
So there's going to be
unique challenges that
make designing
conversational games very
different than your console,
PC, or mobile games.
And so here are some
of the principles
that our team uses to deliver
engaging experiences that users
love.
First, we need to
create the universe.
Think of some of
your favorite games.
What are the worlds that
they transport you to?
Some of my old
school favorites are
things like "Dark Castle," and
"Space Quest," and "Zelda."
And there's this
orchestration of elements
through the backgrounds,
the characters, the story,
the sounds.
They all work together.
But they often rely on visuals
to bring this world to life.
Now with conversational
games, we
don't always have those
elements to work with.
So we need to look for
inspiration elsewhere.
And one of the places
that we can look
is the oral
storytelling techniques
that go back hundreds of years.
So a simple story-starting
phrase like "once upon a time"
helps set the stage in fairy
tales, fables, and myths.
And the origins date
back past the 1400s.
They're also pretty
much universal.
You can find equivalents
in dozens of languages--
so things like "a long time
ago" or "there once lived."
So for us to create
our universe,
we need to set the stage
just like "once upon a time"
does for fairy tales.
It doesn't need
to be much, but it
does help users understand
the world they are in.
So here's a quick example.
If you asked the Assistant
what should I be for Halloween,
it's going to go through
a series of questions
and help you decide a silly
costume that you should wear
when you go trick or treating.
So here are two
approaches on how we can
bring the player into the game.
Let's listen to the first one.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Welcome to
the Halloween costume quiz.
Answer these five
questions to find out
what you should be for
Halloween this year.
ANDY PRATT: All right.
So that technically
does the job.
It brings the user
in a little bit.
It also at least gives feedback
to let users know that they've
entered the right game.
But I think we can do more.
So now let's listen
to this second option.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Wow,
I'm so glad you asked.
I don't want to
toot my own horn,
but I'm kind of an expert.
[DOORBELL]
Oh, hold on.
[GROAN]
CHILDREN: Trick or treat!
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Nice costumes.
Great use of burlap.
Here you go.
CHILDREN: Thank you.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: OK,
run along and have fun.
CHILDREN: Thank you.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: I need
to help someone now.
CHILDREN: Bye.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: OK, let me
assess your costume interests
with a few questions.
Are you ready?
ANDY PRATT: So listen to how
that second version really
starts to set the stage.
And more importantly,
it gets users
excited about playing the game.
So the other thing that
we really need to do
is to kind of look on ways
to layer in sound design.
It's such a critical element,
especially since we have
fewer elements to work with.
So we want to look at ways to
kind of paint this audio world.
Now this can be done
in a couple of ways.
One is kind of through
the background,
so music or atmosphere
to kind of really
help create that whole effect.
Or we can also use it
as a foreground element.
So maybe we want
to use it as a way
to give feedback to
the user that they've
done something right or wrong.
Or we want to use it to
emphasize key moments
of delights or dialogue.
To illustrate this point,
the Google Assistant
has a poem for you--
our loving audience.
It's titled "Bike
and Kickstands.
So let's listen to this.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT:
Thanks for humoring me.
Just give me a few
seconds to write it down.
You're like a bike and
I'm like the kickstand.
Lean on me, friend, when
it's time to make plans.
Whether you're
searching for info,
trying to spell
"chateau," looking
for recipes or other
necessities, I'll always reply.
ANDY PRATT: All right.
So pretty good.
Now, let's hear it with
some sound layered in.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT:
Thanks for humoring me.
Just give me a few
seconds to write it down.
[PENCIL SCRIBBLING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
You're like a bike and
I'm like the kickstand.
[BIKE BELL]
Lean on me, friend, when
it's time to make plans.
Whether you're
searching for info,
trying to spell "chateau,"
looking for recipes
or other necessities, if
you have any questions,
I'll always reply.
ANDY PRATT: Do you feel that?
It's right here.
It's deep inside.
It really just helps
elevate everything.
And so fortunately, later
on in our wonderful program,
we are going to
show you how to add
the love into your dialogue.
Now, another thing
to consider is
how to use sound to
get users to focus.
This can be especially helpful
in multiplayer experiences.
So in our game, "Are
you feeling lucky,"
users are automatically
given names.
And since you can have up
to six players at a time,
we found through our research
that users might forget
when it's their turn to answer.
So to help get users to focus,
we pair them with audio cues.
So let's listen
to how that works.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: OK, just
so everybody is straight,
I'll give you your names again.
They are Nibbler,
[QUACK]
Scooter,
[FLUTE]
Freestyle,
[RECORD SCRATCH]
and Puddles.
[WATER DRIP]
ANDY PRATT: So this
can be a great way just
to kind of associate that
audio cue with that name,
bring users back.
And it's something
that you guys might
want to consider as you're
developing games too.
How can you use audio cues
to get users to focus?
Now, our next principle
is to keep it simple.
Conversations-- they're
inherently linear.
And it's really easy
to move forwards,
but it's much
harder to move back.
We can't ask users to hold
too much in their heads.
So here are a few ways that
you can keep things simple.
The first is use a
consistent structure.
Familiarity is going to make
people feel more comfortable.
And the more we have
deviations, it's
going to increase the
cognitive load of that player
and risk to a higher level of
confusion and possibly errors.
So imagine this--
we're in a quiz.
And here are just two
different questions,
pretty similar in structure.
Now, we restate that question.
And then, we follow
up with the options.
So we still kind of can vary
the language a little bit,
but you can see the
structure is very consistent.
And as the player goes
through the experience,
they're now going to
know what to expect,
allowing them to focus on
the content and not the game
mechanics.
Now, as we push the boundaries
of conversational gameplay,
you may want to
change the structure.
So maybe you want to
have like a bonus round
or something like that.
That's going to be OK as
long as you take the time
and teach the users that
this portion of the game
is going to be different.
So you're going to need to
ultimately weigh is that worth
it.
Is it worth it to take that
time in order to explain it,
even though it may slow
the pace down a bit?
Now, another simple
thing to keep in mind
is when you list out the
choices for a player,
just make sure you follow
up with the exact order.
So if we look at this--
would you rather
travel on a tiny plane
or a surfboard-- we follow up
with plane and then surfboard.
Sometimes it's easy just
to kind of switch those
around, but keep it consistent.
Our next principle is
to keep players engaged.
We don't want your games
to feel like a lecture.
It's very easy for players to
lose focus and get distracted.
One way to do this
is by analyzing
the player's experience
over the course of the game.
So some of you kind of
coming from the game world
may be familiar with the
player interest curve, which
is essentially a way to
represent the highlights
and lowlights of a
player's experience.
And this is going to
be similar to kind
of creating user journey maps.
If you're familiar
with product design
and done some of that, kind
of similar types of concepts.
You're just simply
going to watch
players playing your game.
And you're going to
notice key milestones.
Watch the reactions.
Are they cringing?
Are they excited?
And you're going to
start to plot this.
Now, as you do
this, you're going
to generate these patterns.
And as these patterns
happen, you're
going to want to make
sure that the curve is up.
So looking at a
graph like this, this
is a little bit of a concern.
You can see it starts
off with a great intro
and it ends with an outcome, but
the middle kind of sags a bit.
And we don't want
that to happen.
One way to keep
players engaged is
to make the player part
of the conversation.
Your experience is going to
be directed by the dialogue,
so we want to make
sure that we're always
talking with the player
and not at the player.
You can do this by
creating digestible chunks.
You find moments for your
player to participate.
The other thing that we can
do is respond contextually
whenever possible.
Craft your dialogue based
on that player's response.
So imagine here,
the player is asked
if they would rather play
with a unicorn or a dragon.
And here we have a
very generic response.
So this could be something
for any of the questions.
However in this example, we are
able to respond to something
that's not only a
bit more delightful,
but it also makes the
game feel smarter.
It's providing simple
feedback to the user
that the game understands
what they said.
Now, as we move to kind of
more visual experiences--
smart displays-- what
we're going to want to do
is avoid transcribing word
for word all of the dialogue.
So Thushan mentioned
before the BuzzFeed quiz,
and so here is
kind of an example.
On the right here, we
see this is the TTS.
So this is what
the output will be.
On the left is more of
the experience itself.
So you can see we're not
just using the screen just
to throw all that text in.
We want to simplify it.
We want to move
the user forward.
We want to use the screen
to create that universe.
We also want to just make
sure there's opportunities
to increase the brand and create
more of an emotional connection
with the user.
So don't transcribe
your text word for word.
Another way to keep
players engaged
is to have a great payoff.
Our users' time is very
valuable and there's
a lot of competition
for it, so we
need to make sure that we reward
them for getting to the end.
So if you remember
that interest curve
that I was showing you before,
it ended on that high note.
You guys, as game
designers, are going
to need to figure out what
that payoff is going to be.
All right, our last principle
is to always be playtesting.
Now in the game industry,
this is nothing new.
We know that it's going
to help increase quality.
We know it's going to help find
bugs and basic design flaws.
We also know that engagement
is going to drop off
if the game feels broken.
And we should expect that
errors are going to happen.
Especially with
conversational games,
we know that players can
respond with anything.
The environment may be
polluted-- just kind
of full of background noise.
We definitely got a bit
of that as we were kind of
in the sandbox, and you can kind
of hear all the people around.
There's going to be
situations like that--
if you're at a party--
where it might be tough.
So we have to
anticipate some of that.
We also know that players
may forget what to do next.
A few common errors
that we see are
going to be things
like no input errors,
where the Assistant just hasn't
detected a response at all.
We also see things
like no match errors,
where maybe the Assistant
can't understand the reply.
And we also get
false accept errors,
so this might be where the
Assistant misunderstands
the user, but just kind
of moves along anyway.
So here's a few things that we
can do to minimize those errors
and maximize the fun.
One, start with your concept.
And you can do this
in a very low-fi way.
So have a users, players, read
a script of the happy path,
or essentially the ideal
path of the game play.
You need to make sure that
the gameplay is actually fun.
If the happy path
isn't happy, then it
might be time to look at
ways to iterate on it.
Another thing we do is we like
to test with our eyes closed.
So these are
conversational games.
And you start by
designing with voice only.
You can do this with
a working prototype,
so something like dialogue
flow, or you can also
do this as like a
"Wizard of Oz" technique
where a team member
maybe simulate
the response of the
system, and you kind of
have it set up in this
controlled environment.
This is a great way to help
test the content, the pacing,
and the complexity of
your game mechanics.
Now, the last suggestion
here is to test
with a range of audiences, not
just your primary demographic.
So watch your
parents play with it.
Watch your kids play with it.
They may bubble up issues with
comprehension and complexity
of your dialogue.
They may discover that some
words are just hard to say.
So to wrap up really quick, some
of the basic building blocks
that our team uses are create
the universe, keep it simple,
keep users engaged, and
constantly playtest.
Now, I'm going to
hand it over to Ralfi.
[APPLAUSE]
RALFI NAHMIAS: Hello, everyone.
This is Ralfi, who is also
fun, from Dialogflow team.
Now that you are equipped
with the expert tips
from Andy, let's dive
into how we can actually
implement all of this.
The good news is starting
is really simple.
We are working really
hard on developing
tools and capabilities to make
it easier for you to focus
on what you do the best--
developing games.
At the high level,
developing actions for Google
has three main components.
This applies to any kind of
actions-- games or non-games.
The first step is
you need to build
your conversational flows.
Then, you need to connect
your conversational flow
to your game logic.
And lastly, you need
to publish your actions
to Google Assistant.
For the rest of this
talk, I am going
to focus on Dialogflow, our
industry-leading conversational
agent platform-- creation
platform-- and actions
on Google Console, which
is the tool that you
publish your actions
to Google Assistant.
Dialogflow is a
tool that makes it
super easy to build
conversational flows.
It extracts meaning
from dialogues,
applying machine learning
to the training examples
that you provide.
Let me show you how this works.
Imagine you said the following
sentence-- "send three
dragons to England immediately!
Attack with green
flames for five hours."
Dialogflow understands that
this is about game term.
It's not about user
asking for help
or trying to exit the
game, it's about game term.
It also identifies
important concepts
within this piece of dialogue.
It understands common
concepts like numbers,
countries, colors.
It can also extract specific
concepts about your game,
like characters and weapons.
It's smart enough to understand
some more complex concepts
like time, which is relative.
In this example, when
you say five hours,
it resolves it from the
time that the sentence
was uttered to 5 hours later.
And the cool thing
about Dialogflow
is it comes with built-in
internationalization support.
With just a few clicks,
you can replicate
the same conversational
flow in another language.
If you want to learn
more about Dialogflow,
you can attend a
dedicated session on it
at 3:30 on stage two.
Now that you've built your
actions, it's time to test.
Up until now, you could
only test your actions
using your own developer
account on devices
that are associated with that
particular developer account.
We've just released
a new feature
that allows you to share your
actions with a set of alpha
or beta users.
The alpha release is really
good for testing in design
and development phase.
There are no policy reviews.
And that's the quickest
way to get your testers,
and get feedback, and iterate.
The beta release is for games
that are ready to launch.
It goes through
full review process.
The goal here is to find
edge cases, bugs, and issues
with final polish.
Ultimately, we want you to
produce the best game possible.
After you build,
test, and publish,
you are effectively part
of the Google ecosystem,
so you should make
the most out of that.
The easiest way to do
that is account linking.
It allows your users to use
their own Google accounts
to play your games or they
can link their Google account
to your account
management system.
To set up account
linking, simply
just go to the Account Linking
view on Actions console.
There, you can define
what permissions
you plan to ask from the user.
These permissions are
defined as scopes.
For example, you can ask for
access to user's contacts,
calendar, photos,
or other Google
services they might be using.
From a user's
perspective, they'll
go through this familiar
Google sign-in flow
to use their own Google account
or link the Google account
to their gaming account.
Creating this experience as
a developer is fairly simple.
You just write literally
two lines of code
and use our sign-in helper
function to request sign-in.
Once you do that, you need
to handle user's response.
If the user goes through
the authentication flow
successfully, you'll
receive an access token,
which you can use to access
the resources that you
ask permission for.
If something goes
wrong, you just
need to acknowledge it
and gracefully exit.
One of the key differentiator
of Google Assistant
is the fact that it's
available in various modalities
and enables different
interaction types.
Actions on Google APIs
give you full control
on how to manage these
different interaction types.
Let me quickly go
over what I mean
by these different
interaction types.
The first one is what
we call voice only.
You can think of
your smart speakers.
The whole interaction is
voice-based-- input and output.
The next interaction type
is called voice forward.
These are the smart
speakers you've
seen in the sandbox area.
Here, again, the primary
mode of interaction is voice,
but it's enhanced with
visuals when necessary.
The third interaction
model is intermodal.
You can think of your phone.
Here, you have conversation
and visuals intermixed.
It can start with
the conversation,
switch to a visual,
and go back and forth.
And the last one is visual only.
You can think of your phone
on mute as an example.
Here, there is no
audio input or output.
It's all about visuals and text.
So let's go through an example.
Let's say that a user is playing
your game on a smart speaker.
And then, you want to
show them the image
of their new monster evolved.
We defined the image here.
The first thing we
need to do is we
need to check if the device the
player is playing your game on
has the capability
to show an image.
This capability is
defined as screen output.
If the device has this
capability, great.
We just show the image.
But in our example,
the player is
playing on a smart
speaker, which
doesn't have that capability.
So what we do is we ask the
user to switch to a device that
has this capability.
We do that with a helper
function called NewSurface.
We define what capability
we are looking for,
in this case screen output.
We give the context to the
user on the smart speaker
they are interacting with.
To see your evolved
monster, go to your phone.
And then, we send a
notification to the device
that we want to get the user to.
In this example, we say see
how your monster has evolved.
And then, they can tap
to this notification
and continue their
interaction on their phone.
The final step as a
developer to manage this flow
is you need to handle
the response of the user
for our new surface prompt.
If the user accepts
the prompt, moves
to this new capable device,
then you simply show the image.
If they don't, you just need to
gracefully exit and acknowledge
that you won't be able
to show the image.
Once your game action
starts getting traction,
you need to think
about reengagement.
And we have multiple
ways in our platform
to help you reengage
with your users.
We literally have a section
called user engagement
on our Actions console.
There, you can opt into push
notifications, routines,
and daily update suggestions.
If you opt into
push notifications,
you will be allowed to send
notifications to your users.
Obviously, the users
needs to provide consent.
This is a really
powerful tool, so
it needs to be used
thoughtfully and sparingly.
You can think of routines
as actions chained together.
For example, we have something
like I'm home routine,
where you can bundle a bunch
of apps you want to trigger.
And if you say, hey,
Google, I'm home,
you might have Google
turn on the lights,
adjust the thermostat,
tell you a joke maybe,
and start your
favorite playlist.
Daily updates is also similar.
You set up a daily
notification that reoccurs
every day at a set time.
The user experience for
daily updates and routines
is after your users engage
with your app and exit,
they'll see a
suggestion shipped,
prompting them to add your
action to daily updates
or routines.
Routines may not be that
suitable for gaming vertical,
but something you think about.
I'm just going to focus
on daily updates for now.
This is what your users will see
if you opt into daily updates.
After the user ends
their interaction,
there will be a chip which
says, do you want me to send--
in this case-- jokes daily?
And if the user opts in,
Google will guide the user
through setting the time
of the day when they want
to receive the daily update.
From this point
on, as a developer,
you need to do two things.
First, you need to handle user's
response to the daily update
flow.
If the user goes through
the flow successfully,
you need to acknowledge that.
If not, again, you need
to gracefully exit.
The second step is you need
to define what you actually
want to do when the
daily triggers arrives.
Here, we set to trigger
the update intent.
In the best dad jokes,
example the update intent
would just send a new joke.
Ultimately, this is what
your users will see.
Lastly, I'd like to
talk about monetization
options for your game.
We just announced our
digital goods API here
at I/O, that allows
you to directly sell
digital entitlements using
Google Play infrastructure.
This builds upon our
earlier launch this year,
where you could use your
existing Play entitlements
with Assistant actions.
For example, if you
bought an audiobook
or purchased a
monster in your game,
you could actually use it
in your Google Assistant.
What digital goods API does is
it makes the reverse also true.
If you have a transaction
in your action,
the same entitlement can be
used in your Android app.
Let me go through an example
from our partners in Headspace
to show you how this could
work on a smart display.
For those of you who don't
know about Headspace,
they are a company who build
products on guided meditation.
So let's say that
a session is over
and Headspace offers
the option to subscribe.
The user responds with
an intent to subscribe.
And the action shows
the available options
in a very curated
and visual way.
The user picks an option
and is handed over
to the checkout flow.
Here, if you enabled
account linking
and the user already has account
credentials stored with Google,
the checkout will
be very seamless.
You just with a single
tap or a command,
you'll have your
premium content that
can be reused on the Assistant,
and also on Android apps.
With that, I'm going
to hand it back
to Thushan, who's going to talk
about implementing some best
practices in your games.
[APPLAUSE]
THUSHAN AMARASIRIWARDENA: So
now, we're going to pump it up.
If you remember back
when Andy was talking,
we showed the difference of
what sound design can do.
These devices really rely
on music, sound effects,
and voice.
And we have some
technology that we
wanted to showcase that can
help you pump it up quite a bit.
You could, for example,
record tons and tons of lines
with a voice actor and
get a sound engineer
to add sound effects and
make some beautiful audio.
Or you could use this
technology called
SSML, which is Speech
Synthesis Markup
Language, that allows you to
do it in real time in code.
And what that also
allows you to do
is to put variables
along the way.
Now, we have this
static poem, but imagine
if it said, thank you
for humoring me, Thushan.
You could add
personalization to it,
and yet still have that
dynamic sound effects and all.
So here's our script.
And we're going to
start pumping it up.
SSML is just like HTML,
you just add tags.
You wrap it in a speak tag.
You put paragraph tags
when you have each line.
And then, you can
start doing things
like adding sound effects.
And it's a simple audio
URL from your server.
But there's more than just
text and sound effects.
There's sound
layering, and that's
what we're going
to talk about here.
We have a tag called media.
What media does is allow
you to essentially, make
two or multiple tracks, and
then layer them together.
This is our first track here.
And we're going to call it poem.
And it's going to
start one second in.
And you'll see why in a second.
We add another sound effect.
And we even put a
little dramatic pause.
And then, we work
on our music loop.
We call it music.
We can control how many
times it loops through,
set the sound level, if we
want it to fade in or fade out.
And then, we use that name from
earlier when the poem ends.
Let's run it for another second.
And then, we have our
music loop itself.
So altogether, we
wrap it in another tag
called parallel, or par.
And that runs both of
those tracks together.
Now, what I showed you here is a
truncated version of that poem,
but let's hear that example.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT:
Thanks for humoring me.
Just give me a few
seconds to write it down.
[PENCIL SCRIBBLING]
THUSHAN AMARASIRIWARDENA:
Sound effects.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
GOOGLE ASSISTANT:
You're like a bike
and I'm like the kickstand.
[BIKE BELL]
THUSHAN AMARASIRIWARDENA:
We've go the music.
We've got that sound effect.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Lean on me,
friend, when it's time to make
plans.
Whether you're
searching for info,
trying to spell "chateau,"
looking for recipes
or other necessities, if
you have any questions,
I'll always reply.
THUSHAN AMARASIRIWARDENA:
And that fadeout.
And it's all done in code.
The other big thing we
want to leave you with
is if you make something
and no one hears it,
not only is that a
punch in the gut,
but you're wondering what you
can do to make that happen.
So we want to tell
you that very,
very soon, we're going to
be opening up "hey, Google,
let's play a game"
to all developers.
This is called a
built-in intent.
There are other talks about it,
but register your app for it.
Consider it the app store of
games on the Google Assistant.
And when someone says
"play a game," which
is what a lot of
our users are doing,
they'll get a list of
the games available.
And this works on both
smart displays, phones,
and smart speakers.
But to make that happen, we
have a little homework for you.
Go back into your actions
on Google console,
and fill out all the metadata.
That's what we use
to look at your app,
know what it is about,
and feature it with users.
So make sure you
have beautiful icons
and your descriptions
are great there.
And I'm going to tell
you a little secret--
we don't usually talk
about how we rank things,
but I wanted to highlight this.
This is how we look for quality.
Straight up quality,
be it it sounds great,
the gameplay is great, and users
are loving it and rating it.
We're looking for long sessions
and games that have people
coming back for more and more.
We're looking for games that
map to those core demographics
of millennials,
families, and kids.
And we're looking
for games that aren't
like the others around there.
We want to offer our users
a wide variety of games.
And then, if you can update
your apps regularly and feature
the new tech, like jumping
onto those smart displays,
that will give you a great shot
of getting in front of users.
So we want to leave
you with one last note.
I think many of you have
been on the touchscreen
revolution of making apps.
And we think there's an
opportunity very similar
here with these smart speakers
and digital assistants.
And on behalf of the Dialogflow,
the ActionsOnGoogle team
and Assistant, we know that it's
hard, but we're here for you.
We want to see you succeed.
And we would love
to hear from you.
I'm going to show you our
email addresses later,
but we think there's
an opportunity
to become the household name
of conversation, and play,
and games.
And we want it to be you--
all of you.
Thank you so much.
Please leave us feedback.
And take a snapshot of
our email addresses.
We would love to
hear from you, be
it new or questions
about how to use it,
and apps that you're making.
We'd love to play with them.
Thanks so much.
And we can't wait
to play your games.
[MUSIC PLAYING]